Jennifer it's great to see you I know
this must have been great to be with you
it must have been wild for you to watch
this over the last few days all over
again just your first year just initial
reaction to watching him he got clearly
got the body language yet the arms
crossed he was right it was very angry
that this reporter asked him kind of
some fairly logical questions I would I
would imagine right right well my first
impression was he's just not as good a
liar anymore as it used to be he's not
on his game where that's concerned yeah
I think Bill is afraid you know I'm
advocating that Bill be prosecuted for
his sex crimes just like Harvey
Weinstein has been arrested and Bill
Cosby is is about to be sentenced why
not Bill Clinton he's nervous that's why
he's acting that way and you know
probably has some health problems and
it's affected his ability to respond as
well as he used to be and until eyes as
good as he used to well you're a young
woman 27 years old when you first you
know got involved with him you know he
was married
and you or not and you started having
this relationship at some point you
you've now decided that it became a
non-consensual harassment relationship
which doesn't really comport with what
you originally how you originally
classified this so now how are you all
these years later claiming that it was
that it was non-consensual at some point
it's very interesting because back in
1977 when I met bill we didn't have the
laws to protect as we as women we were
in I was in the workplace in a man's
world I just had to do the best that I
could when I first met Bill Clinton it
was when I was sent out on my first
story by myself after my training with
my cameraman he came on to me that night
I told him to knock it off he proceeded
to continue to come on to me for three
months before I decided that I wanted to
have a relationship with him which at
that point was consensual but in today's
and urns and in hindsight it was
definitely sexual harassment I was a
little bit ashamed to admit that because
in a way I mean I was I felt guilty
because I was a willing participant at a
point so I felt guilty about saying that
I was sexually harassed in the beginning
but I definitely was absolutely when you
say you want him present when my yet
when you when you say you want him
prosecuted Jennifer why not not for not
for what because with sexual harassment
it's not it's a civil that's a civil
case but for the criminal prosecution
are you referring are you referring to
one ada Broderick obviously absolutely
Juanita
he raped Juanita I've met Juanita she is
a beautiful person I wanted to like
Hillary I wanted to be in denial I
wanted to deny that these things could
happen because I felt like that that
wasn't the person that I had known but
when I met her the first time
and realized that she was a very genuine
person and had no reason to lie about
that I had to come to terms with the
fact that he was very capable and did do
that why shouldn't he be prosecuted for
rape as Bill Cosby has and and Harvey
Weinstein was just arrested why
shouldn't he be
why don't they why don't they arrest
Hillary as a as a co-conspirator
because she has allowed him she has been
the the person that has let him go and
the enabler that has let him go in and
do what he's done to women the by the
way we reached out to the Clinton
Foundation to Bill Clinton's personal
attorney David Kendall about this story
and about your new allegations and we
did not get a response so we did
attempted not Bill Clinton said this I
want to I want to play another little
snippet from Bill Clinton this was also
from this New York event last night
let's watch okay I support the me to
movement and I think it's long overdue
and I have always tried to support it
in the decisions and policies that I've
advanced he supports the nature movement
Jennifer and what he wants people do
yeah believe him at this point now
that's the fourth biggest lie and that's
the fourth biggest lie you know some of
what the others are he has he would say
that of course what would he say but
that he is in support of it he's been a
huge abuser of the me to movement and I
would like for the me to movement to be
so kind as to recognize myself and Paul
and Juanita and Kathleen and many many
other women starting many years ago that
have come out with claims of sexual
harassment from Bill Clinton they
haven't given us any respect as far as
I'm concerned we're the me not movement
that's what we are why do you think they
haven't it just seems like that the
Clintons are bulletproof that it doesn't
matter what they do they seem to get
away with things and this would be
another instance of that he just he
hasn't been held accountable and how are
you doing I don't know that's a good
question
that's a good question well I mean why
would a lot of people that yeah I think
the me to movement there's a lot of good
stuff going on but sadly a lot of it is
pine forest a lot of it is politicized
and their wife Anita Broderick they
don't count people like you know
Kathleen Willey they don't count how are
you doing by the way we're out of time
but how are you doing and after all
these years you look great by the way
but how are you doing thank you god
bless you oh and I love you by the way
I'm a big fan I'm doing fine I getting
ready to do a little reboot of my book
and I've I lost my mother in July last
year so that that's been a huge thing to
overcome but I'm doing good thank you
for asking I'm good thank you for having
me absolutely Jennifer we really
appreciate your perspective and this
Clintons they just they never do seem to
go away and we appreciate it the